rfi et france 24
présente mardi politique
[Musique]
c'est l'heure de mardi politique sur
france 24 rfi bonsoir frédéric rivière
bonsoir aux immenses aura tous alors ce
soir nous recevons geoffroy didier
député européen les républicains et
vice-président de la région
ile-de-france bonsoir à vous bonsoir et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors nicolas sarkozy condamné hier à
trois ans de prison dont un ferme pour
corruption et trafic d'influencé
les juges ont suivi le réquisitoire du
parquet national financiers les avocats
ont fait appel
alors vous connaissez cette phrase jean
de la fontaine selon que vous soyez
puissant ou misérable les jugements de
cour vous rendront blanc ou noir alors
aujourd'hui faut-il avoir peur lorsqu'on
est puissant je voudrais d'abord vous
dire que la procédure judiciaire est
toujours en cours que certes il y a eu
une décision de première instance
mais qu'à partir du moment où nicolas
sarkozy a fait le choix d'interjeter
appel la décision de première instance
n'existe plus elle n'existe en ayant
comme dirait que nicolas sarkozy est
innocent jusqu'à ce qu'il y ait une
éventuelle des films décision définitive
qui disent le contraire
je le dis pourquoi parce que en fait
bien sûr que nicolas sarkozy n'est pas
un justiciable comme les autres
mais j'aimerais aussi qu'il soit traité
comme un justiciable comme les autres et
que healy interne
intel 1 leurs efforts nous expliquer
d'ogm il est il et il est un justiciable
comme les autres
c'est ce que je souhaite et vous
considérez qu'il ne l'est pas non car
par cette chambre mais au braquage pour
toi sinon il ne l'est pas dans la mesure
où comme ancien président de la
république
toute décision le concernant bénéficie
d'un retour médiatique massif
il suffit de regarder autour de nous les
caméras qui ont suivi la décision de
justice mais je voudrais justement dans
ce brouhaha médiatique rappeler une
vérité simple c'est que nicolas sarkozy
et ce soir innocent jusqu'à une
éventuelle décision de la boe n'a pu
renoncer un train si oui et qui mérite
d'être assez selon moi qui méritent
selon douar d'innocence
non mais maintenant tous les grands
titres trade de tous les grands titres
traite de la décision de justice et de
la condamnation
je le dis la procédure judiciaire est en
cours il nicolas sarkozy est innocent ce
soir reste qu' il y a le tribunal l'a
condamné à trois ans prison dont un an
avec sursis et c2 cette condamnation que
nicolas sarkozy fait appel donc on peut
pas la faire disparaître comme ça et on
peut s'interroger sur ce que représente
pour vous cette formation vous qui avait
été un moment donné l'un des fondateurs
des croix les amis de nicolas sarkozy
vous qui avait été son porte parole dans
certains combats politiques
qu'est ce que ça représente pour vous ça
représente
je vous dis je
je fais la part des choses entre d'un
côté justiciables qui nicolas sarkozy et
qui souhaite que son honneur soit lavé
et qui donc fait le choix d'utiliser le
voies de recours qui existent parce
qu'il n'est pas d'accord sur le fond
avec ses décisions de justice et puis il
y a le soutien personnel que l'on peut
lui apporter parce que nous avons
beaucoup aimé nicolas sarkozy comme
président de la république et qu'il
constitue indubitablement une référence
pour la droite française
mais ce sont deux sujets parce que dans
l'esprit de nicolas sarkozy il n'a pas
il ne souhaite pas être jugé comme un
politique ou comme un ancien président
de la république
il souhaite juste retrouver son honneur
et être traité comme un justiciable
comme les autres
je veux que ce que je vais vous dire par
la mauvaise c'est que c'est que je fais
vraiment la part des choses entre le
droit et la politique et entre
justiciables qu'ils aient et l'ancien
président de la république il est aussi
et qui fait de lui une référence
effectivement pour l'ensemble la droite
france mais quand vous dites il n'est
pas traité comme un justiciable comme
les autres
on va pas tourner autour du pot certains
à droite disent peu le pnf s'est
transformé le parquet le parquet
national financier oui
et transformer en outil de pour
combattre l'opposition et l'opposition
de droite
c'est en quelque sorte une organisation
politique
est-ce que ça le disent certains le dit
est ce que ça mais vous estiment avoir
un devoir de prudence parce que je ne
suis pas seulement responsable politique
je suis aussi avocat et lorsqu'on est
avocat on essaie d'être rigoureux avec
le droit et on respecte les décisions du
6 quelle qu'elle soit mais la justice
est humaine
le juge dit le droit mais bénéficie
d'une palette de sanctions possibles on
peut comme avocat et même comme citoyens
d'ailleurs désapprouvé ne pas être
d'accord avec une décision de justice
c'est la raison pour laquelle dans
toutes les démocraties il existe des
voies de recours
donc moi je ne vous dis pas comme
d'ailleurs beaucoup de responsables
politiques ma famille politique
c'est un acharnement judiciaire c'est un
acharnement judiciaire jeudi
il existe plusieurs degrés de
juridiction nicolas sarkozy désapprouve
la décision sur le plan juridique c'est
un dossier avant d'être à un brouhaha
médiatique et donc oui il interjette
appel et j'espère que la vérité sera
rétabli pourquoi parce que quelle que
soit l'issue finale de ce dossier ma
conviction intime restera intact c'est
celle de l'honnêteté de nicolas sarkozy
l'accusation se fonde en partie en très
grande partie même sur des écoutes us
que vous raisonnez vous parlez beaucoup
en droit en tant qu'avocat donc sur des
écoutes téléphoniques notamment entre
nicolas sarkozy et l'un de ses avocats
est-ce qu'en droit on peut pratiquer on
peut recourir à ces méthodes
ou est-ce que là on efface véritablement
à une singularité cette décision elle me
pose un problème de principe sur le fond
parce qu'elle contrevient à la
jurisprudence constante de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme selon
laquelle il doit exister un secret
absolu de correspondance j'ai envie de
dire même de confidences entre un avocat
et son client
mais je
dis pas seulement comme avocat je le dis
comme justiciables je m'adresse à vous
chacun de nous peut être demain inquiété
par la justice
avoir le droit à la défense et avoir le
droit au secret ce secret n'a pas été
respecté via des écoutes et j'estime que
cette décision de justice
elle pose un problème de société et de
protection pour n'importe quel
justiciable
car je crois nécessaire de protéger au
maximum ce secret de correspondance de
confinance bref ce secret professionnel
qui existe entre un avocat et son client
mais parlons de ce parc national
financier puisque aujourd'hui c'est à la
limite aujourd'hui on parle plus du pn
9,1 de ce parc national financiers
plutôt que de ce qui arrive à nicolas
sarkozy ce pnf ce parquet est contesté
ont dit qu'ils abusent des enquêtes
préliminaires il a été créé en 2013 sous
françois hollande pour qui était une
réponse morale en quelque sorte à la
faire cahuzac
donc c'était piste et l'évasion fiscale
pisté les gaffes à est ce que vous
considérez aujourd'hui que son rôle est
dévoyée les objectifs
ce sont les bons vous vous disiez piste
et l'évasion fiscale le pister les
gaffes alors ce qu'elles commettent des
actes illégaux je le dis aussi comme
député au parlement européen
bien sûr que ce sont des objectifs qui
sont tout à fait louables
après il ya les méthodes et c'est la
raison pour laquelle je vous disais la
justice est humaine et que l'on a droit
aussi d'apprécier la manière dont les
juges agissent et la mise en cause du
pfl ne vient pas de moi elle vient des
journalistes puisque j'ai lu cette
semaine une longue enquête de presse sur
les dérives éventuelles et présumé un
point du pmf dans le point donc je ne
peux pas en tant que citoyen ne pas
m'interroger sur la question de savoir
si ce tribunal d'exception et d'ailleurs
je me méfie de ces tribunaux d'exception
qui sont en train de se généraliser
je me méfie de la judiciarisation sans
doute excessive de la vie politique
pourquoi parce que ça peut être une
entrave à l'action publique
et ça peut même le l'avions vu pendant
la dernière campagne présidentielle avec
la sphère fillon ça peut même être une
entrave au débat public
donc je crois que dans la société chacun
doit tenter de jouer son rôle avec
mesure avec le sens de l'équilibré et je
suis plutôt méfiants pour répondre à
votre question à l'égard des
juridictions d'exception qui ont
tendance en ce moment a su multiplier en
revanche que des juges doit vous mettez
bestial et lisa sion dans votre
vocabulaire ans mais parce que at mais
où
mais parce qu'on n'est pas là pour
fustiger si vous souhaitiez de moi que
je viens de vous dire non comme
responsables politiques de droite qui
lie à tous les juges contre nicolas
sarkozy
je ne sais pas si vous avez entendu la
voix de l'actrice se dit la même chose
je veux pas mais il estime que nous
avons un devoir de mesure et que en
revanche nicolas sarkozy a raison
d'interjeter appel parce que je ne suis
pas d'accord sur le fond avec cette
décision de justice
mais pourquoi parce que j'estime lisez
et j'imagine que vous l'avez fait la
décision
elle ne parle pas de preuves de
faisceaux à elles demeurées de vol
faisceau d'indicés ou d'un indice c'est
à dire que nicolas sarkozy a été
condamné même si encore une fois il est
présumé innocent sans preuve
un mot peut-être avant d'aborder va
falloir qu'on aborde d'autres sujets
nécessairement je suis là pour répondre
à l'europe et la crise sanitaire
peut-être mais d'un mot est ce que c'est
un coup dur pour la droite
est ce que la droite voie d'une certaine
manière peut-être s'échapper un
quelqu'un qui aurait pu être un recours
éventuellement pour la présidentielle
2022 en la personne de nicolas sarkozy
j'ai bien fait de vous dire qu'il ya
quelques instants que je faisais une
grande différence entre la politique et
le droit
ouais nicolas sarkozy pour nous c'est
une référence
oui je lis beaucoup soutenu
politiquement il s'est lui-même retiré
de la politique partisane je continue à
le soutenir personnellement et je crois
que ce qu'ils demandent c'est non pas
d'être remis en selle politiquement
c'est de voir son honneur rétabli par la
vérité des faits et par la
reconnaissance de l'autorité judiciaire
si vous voulez en revanche frédéric
rivière que l'on parle de la campagne
présidentielle de 2022
certes il ya déjà des candidats
sur les starting blocks mais je n'ai pas
entendu de la part de nicolas sarkozy
une volonté de revenir dans la vie
politique
mais est ce que ces affaires judiciaires
parce que quand il y en a d'autres
il ya un calendrier judiciaire qui
attend nicolas sarkozy est la prochaine
étape c'est la sphère bygmalion est ce
que ces affaires judiciaires ne
vont-elles pas été la droite en quelque
sorte à couper le cordon avec nicolas
sarkozy comme s'il était il restait un
espoir suspendu qui empêchait toute
autre personnalité d'émerger et je
rajouterais et bien que vous la droite a
pas su tuer le père la justice l'a fait
non je ne crois pas il est une référence
pour une raison simple c'est qu'il est
le dernier président de la république de
droit il aimait de france et une
référence qui est encore suspendue dans
longtemps mais c'est vous qui le le
vivez comme ça mais il ya une nouvelle
génération politique qui a pris les
commandes il y a 6 ans un président de
la région ile-de-france valérie pécresse
comme président de la région auvergne
rhône-alpes laurent wauquiez xavier
bertrand qui lui même a déjà dit qu'il
souhaitait porter les couleurs de la
droite pour l'élection présidentielle
donc et ils ont tous été ministre de
nicolas sarkozy mais il ya une vie après
nicolas sarkozy et nous en restions
justement mais sans doute vaudrait la
région mais je ne la partage pas et ça
n'enlève en rien l'affection et le
soutien personnel que j'adresse une
nouvelle incroyable de la sarkozie mais
je crois que nous élus d'une autre
génération
nous avons le devoir aussi mais pourquoi
parce que le monde a changé parce que le
nouveau monde le vrai nouveau monde
pourtant théorisée par emmanuel macron
est en train d'arriver
est ce que vous imaginez un instant que
lorsque l'on sortira de la crise
sanitaire peut-être est-ce une
transition pour en parler cher frédéric
rivière que les choses seront les mêmes
qu'auparavant non tout a changé notre
regard sur la vie a changé notre regard
sur les pouvoirs publics sur le
fonctionnement de l'état est en train de
changer
donc j'ai bien ris on parle du passé
politique mais je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup à faire pour la nouvelle
génération à laquelle j'appartiens alors
pour aborder donc la crise sanitaire par
le prisme européen puisque vous êtes
député européen est ce que vous pensez
que la commission européenne
n'a pas fait ce qu'il fallait en fait en
matière de commandes de vaccins à la
fois sur le rythme peut-être sur les
quantités sur la négociation des
contrats
d'ailleurs on ne sait pas grand chose là
dessus puisqu'il ya beaucoup de
d'opacité sur les contrats est-ce que
vous ne vous dites pas au fond que la
grande bretagne qui elle vaccine à tour
de bras donne raison aux détracteurs de
l'union européenne non je me dise où
contraire pardon être à contre-courant
mais je suis un défenseur de l'europe
dans la mesure
non pas pour le principe mais dans la
mesure où heureusement que la commande
des vaccins s'est fait à l'échelle
européenne
pensez vous un instant que nous aurions
pu nous français commandé tout seul des
vaccins alors que nous n'avons pas de
lieux de production
nous n'avions pas de lieu de production
des vaccins en france nous n'avions pas
de vaccin et les français qui ont créé
et astrazeneca ou moderna on les a
laissés partir parce que nous sommes
incapables d'investir massivement dans
la recherche donc toutes les personnes
qui se disent souverainistes ou qui font
du patriotisme à l'emporte-pièce ne
pourront pas vous expliquer que nous
aurions été plus efficace si nous avions
fonctionner seul avec nos petits bras
plutôt qu'à l'échelle européenne je
pense que nous avons eu raison de
commander les vaccins l'échelle
européenne
parce que pour concurrencer israël
n'avait pas de vaccin on est très bien
sorti oui mais israël a été beaucoup
plus efficace parce que je crois que au
sein de l'animation et de l'union
européenne et sans avoir de médecin
ce que je veux vous dire c'est que
heureusement que la commande des vaccins
s'est fait à l'échelle européenne je
regrette en revanche une absence de
transparence sur la négociation des
contrats est ce que je regrette aussi
clairement c'est la manière dont le
gouvernement français et
l'administration française prise dans
ses propres mais andré dans sa propre
complexité bousille le travail je le dis
clairement bousille le travail de
l'union européenne qui a commandé des
vaccins à temps et qui certes aurait dû
être plus transparentes
lorsque j'ai change avec des maires de
ma région l'ile-de-france qui me disent
qu'ils ont créé des vaccinodromes des
centres vaccinaux mais qu' ils ont
attendu les vaccins qu'on leur avait
pourtant promis au niveau gouvernemental
pour des problèmes d'acheminement qu'une
fois le vaccin
arrivés ils ont dû eux même acheté des
seringues et des aiguilles parce que
l'administration française et la rs
était incapable de leur fournir ces
seringue et ses aiguilles comme si on
allait donner le vaccin par télépathie
et non par piqûre il y a un problème
majeur de la bureaucratie française et
de l' agence régionale de la santé qui
est devenu un état dans l'état et qui
sait donner les pleins pouvoirs alors
qu'en réalité le ferait mieux de faire
preuve d'une très grande humilité face
aux isérois se les est donné en tout cas
selon ce que vous dites c'est qu'on lui
a laissé aussi bien sûr mais si mes mais
ce que je vous dis c'est que il ya aussi
une responsabilité politique c'est pour
ça que j'ai commencé par vous parler du
gouvernement français l'europe n'est pas
infaillible
et si je suis devenu député au parlement
européen c'est précisément pour la
réformer de l'intérieur
mais j'estime que face à la crise
sanitaire heureusement que nous étions
unis et ensemble c'est à dire le premier
marché économique nous sommes le premier
marché économique du monde
vous croyez que les laboratoires
pharmaceutiques privées qui sont en ce
moment sollicité par tous les pays du
monde
aurait négocié de la même manière avec
uniquement la france qu'avec le premier
marché économique mondiale c'est à dire
l'union européenne
non il n'aurait pas fait de la même
manière et nous n'étions pas
malheureusement suffisamment puissant
pour fonctionner tout seul
encore une fois nous sommes suspendus
d'entre eux un semis confinement un
confinement week-end dans certaines
régions est ce que vous considérez que
nous fait un peu l'internet
il faut s'adapter et on ne peut
gouverner comme ça en fait en vérité qu
au pied du géant
jour par jours ou semaines par semaine
est-ce que la stratégie vous paraît la
bonne chance que dans trente secondes
geoffroy dit je trouve la réponse est
dans votre question on gère cette crise
sanitaire à la petite semaine
alors qu'il va falloir apprendre à vivre
avec le co vide parce que chacun a bien
compris que cette crise sanitaire qui
n'allait pas s'arrêter du jour au
lendemain et qu'il faudrait s'organiser
pourquoi par exemple ne crée ton pas des
tests salivaires qui permettront demain
de réouvrir les lieux culturels et lieux
de vie aussi importants que sont par
exemple les restaurants et les cafés
voilà merci aux français merci merci
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur plateau
france 24 rfi merci à charlotte rien
thomas k et à camille née rang pour
avoir réparé cette émission oui et à
toute l'équipe technique à la semaine
prochaine frédéric
[Musique]
du grand nord canadien jusqu'à ushuaia
toute l'actualité politique économique
culturel et social du continent
américain gap amériques présentée par
elisabetta là à regarder sur france 24
et france 24 points comme